mes chers collègues madame la rapporteur
madame et Messieurs notre commission
d'enquête sur la pénurie de médicaments
et les choix d'industrie pharmaceutiques
françaises poursuit ses travaux par
l'audition conjointe de plusieurs
syndicats et représentant de médecins
l'audition de l'Académie de médecine du
conseil national de l'ordre des médecins
de la terre Syndicat national des
praticiens d'exercices hospitaliers nous
avaient permis le mois dernier de
recueillir le témoignage des
prescripteurs sur les phénomènes de
pénurie parce que les médecins sont en
première ligne face aux difficultés
d'approvisionnement il nous a toutefois
sans bien indispensables d'entendre plus
largement aujourd'hui le représentant
les pénuries de médicaments
affecte en effet largement l'exercice
médical comme ça nous l'a été confirmé
dans les auditions précédentes lors de
leur audition l'Académie et le conseil
national de l'ordre ont particulièrement
insisté sur le manque d'information des
médecins la perte de confiance des
patients la difficulté d'adapter les
stratégies thérapeutiques et les risques
iatrogéniques ou de surdosage enduit en
outre s'ajoute à cette liste de retard
de prise en charge thérapeutiques voire
pour certains de renoncement
ces éléments ont un coût au sens propre
comme au sens figuré pour la santé
publique et celle des patients enfin on
parle de médicaments en pénurie bien
évidemment et sous tendu la question des
contingentements qui restent aussi à un
sujet qui n'est pas négligeable dans
l'exercice quotidien
ainsi que l'on nous attendons de vous
aussi la mesure de l'ensemble des
difficultés notamment le temps médical
et la perte de temps passé à traiter ces
questions y compris en lien avec les
pharmaciens comme ça a été témoignés
largement dans la table ronde que nous
avons eu avec les représentants des
pharmaciens
nous souhaiterions donc
identifier les évolutions qui pourraient
permettre de faire évoluer positivement
ces pénuries et de mieux les maîtriser
donc autour de la table nous accueillons
le docteur cavalero directeur général de
MG France le 2 alors voilà le docteur
Bruno Perotti en distance qui est
président du syndicat des spécialistes
la CSF le docteur Corinne le Sauveur
président de la Fédération des médecins
de France la FMF et le docteur Benoît
Coulon président de médecin pour demain
alors pas président justement du conseil
d'administration membre du conseil
d'administration de médecins pour demain
politique
je vous remercie donc Madame et
Messieurs de vous être rendus disponible
aujourd'hui nous souhaiterions que vous
puissiez présenter très concrètement
dans un bref propos introductif la
manière dont les pénuries de médicaments
affectent la prise en charge des
patients les conditions de travail des
médecins ainsi que les difficultés que
vous rencontrez au quotidien je vous
serez de retour à tour la parole pour
une durée de 5 minutes que je vous
demanderai de ne pas dépasser donc c'est
bien 5 minutes puisque vous êtes
nombreux à avoir répondu à notre
invitation à laquelle nous tenions
d'ailleurs et nous nous en félicitons
puis madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
une première série de questions suivies
par les collègues qui sont ici présent
je vous précise que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est passive des peines prévues
aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 430
du code pénal je vous invite chacun à
votre tour à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure monsieur carvallero
vous a pas entendu
docteur Ledeur
et docteur Coulon
voilà je vous remercie et donc
maintenant vous donner successivement la
parole dans l'ordre d'intervention voilà
docteur cavalier alors moi je suis je
suis pas docteur
donc la question sur de la rupture des
approvisionnements dans certaines
molécules posent avant toute la question
de la logique financière liée à ces
industrie ce qui aboutit notamment un
arrêt de fabrication d'anciennes
molécules peu rentable financièrement
mais indispensable dans le panel
thérapeutique du médecin généraliste au
quotidien d'autant que ces molécules
sont souvent sans aucun équivalent de
substitution cela aboutit également un
déséquilibre entre dans les dépenses de
santé entre le budget médicament et les
ressources disponibles pour les
professionnels de santé
la question de la rupture de
l'approvisionnement ne signifie pas que
les médecins sur prescrivent comme on a
pu l'entendre
hors contexte épidémique lié par exemple
à cet hiver désigner les généralistes
comme responsables est une erreur
d'analyse toutefois concernée par
l'enjeu d'une meilleure pertinence de
prescription nous sommes demandeurs du
dispositif d'une gamme énergie de tropes
à effectuer au cabinet pour essayer des
diagnostics et des indications c'est
sans doute une voie intéressante pour
l'avenir face à ces ruptures les
médecins généralistes s'adaptent au
mieux le risque est celui des ruptures
qui s'enchaînent les unes après les
autres jusqu'à ce que les indications
deviennent de moins en moins pertinentes
et où les risques d'effets secondaires
sont pourraient être de plus en plus
élevés
les ruptures ne concernent pas que les
médicaments thérapeutiques mais
également les vaccins avec le risque
d'une diminution de la couverture
vaccinale de la population ainsi le
vaccin contre l'hépatite B a été en
rupture pendant plusieurs années et le
BCG a été indisponible jusqu'en janvier
2023 les médecins s'inquiètent des
risques pour la santé de leur passion en
raison de substitution approximative
retarde de délivrance traitement
incomplet inobservance des patients par
crainte de la rupture ou d'un manque de
confiance dans la nouvelle molécule au
nouveau médicament voilà
j'ai respecté les 5 minutes je pense
[Rires]
en fait est pas si récent que ça parce
que on le vit depuis de très nombreuses
années non pas sur des ruptures
complètes mais sur des réorientations
d'approvisionnement de médicaments vers
d'autres pays d'Europe et régulièrement
les grossistes disent qu'ils soient
qu'ils étaient en rupture de médicaments
et du coup les patients nous disaient
les pharmaciens disaient il y a plus
alors que si on appelait le laboratoire
fabricant il y avait encore et ça ça
date au moins d'une dizaine d'années et
ça a mis des patients en difficulté
parce qu'il y avait plus assez de
médicaments en stocke chez les
grossistes et puis maintenant on voit
que c'est carrément des problèmes de
fabrication c'est apparu surtout ça donc
au des cours du covid avec les problèmes
de mondialisation de la fabrication des
médicaments qui est vraiment un sujet et
de la nécessaire
relocalisation de la fabrication je
crois que c'est ruptures
d'approvisionnement qui sont conseils
pur et dures c'est assez difficile parce
qu'on fait de la peu près on est obligé
de trouver un médicament qui ressemble
qui est pas toujours identique qui a pas
toujours les mêmes effets secondaires
qui pour le patient pose problème
puisqu'il n'a pas la même apparence et
pas nécessairement la même absorption et
les mêmes conditions d'utilisation
c'est un médicament comme on va dire le
doliprane enfance à pose problème parce
que
un enfant qui est fébrile ça peut avoir
des complications je suis neurologue et
je peux dire qui peut y avoir des
convulsions fébriques qui pourraient
être évité grâce à simple absorption
doliprane les antibiotiques c'était
aussi une grosse problématique puisqu'il
y a des complications de d'angine non
soigné à condition qu'elle soit qu'elle
nécessite des antibiotiques ces objets
et dans les pathologies plus graves
c'est encore plus inquiétant parce que
je pense moi des patients épileptiques
des patients parking Sonia qui ont des
médicaments ou il faut qu'on bricole on
passe je vous prends un exemple je vais
faire vite dans le parking sun on a
trois médicaments monopard cinémates et
stadevo oui c'est la lévodopomme et
c'est pas la même chose c'est pas
absorber la même manière et on risque
d'avoir un patient qui tout d'un coup se
bloque au risque de faire des
complications
on est discuter importante et je crois
que c'est donc
vraiment très important qu'on arrive à
résoudre rapidement ce problème de
rupture d'approvisionnement et de
fabrication voilà je vous remercie
très bien merci beaucoup docteur Le
Soler
voilà alors le sauter il y a pas de l
mais c'est pas grave dans mon nom c'est
simplement si vous le voulez voilà mais
c'est pas gênant oui tout à fait il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
mais c'est vrai que nous en tant que
prescripteur on est vraiment au bout de
la chaîne et on est face à nos patients
et donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très important et on le voit surtout en
pédiatrie où il y a énormément de
problèmes pédiatriques
suite à des manques d'antibiotiques on a
eu aussi les manques de d'anti-pyrétique
et donc ça c'est quand même important on
le voit actuellement là aussi avec un
manque de traitement pour pour l'asthme
et on a beaucoup de gens allergiques et
en ce moment c'est beaucoup le problème
s'il vous plaît chers collègues donc les
pharmaciens aussi sont en contact direct
avec les patients
on communique les uns avec les autres
voilà et ça nous prend beaucoup de temps
ça parce qu'effectivement quand on est
jamais au bout on n'est jamais au
courant d'une rupture de d'une rupture
de médicaments et donc ça c'est vraiment
embêtant parce que les mêmes les
pharmaciens quand ils voient que leur
boîte est vide et qu'ils essaient
d'obtenir et ben ils en ont pas non plus
donc c'est vrai qu'on arrive vraiment à
des choses vraiment quelquefois
je vais dire catastrophique parce que
c'est une perte de chance c'est c'est un
temps perdu aussi nous pendant notre
temps de consultation et notre temps
médical est quelque chose de très
compter donc c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut vraiment revoir donc ça
c'est quelque chose d'important et alors
on se rend compte effectivement là j'ai
fait le tour avec plusieurs confrères
parce qu'en fait on se rend compte que
ce qui manque du Val de Loire ce qui
manque dans le Val de Loire ne manque
pas dans le sud de la France ne manque
pas dans l'est et donc j'ai fait un
petit tour là pour savoir par rapport à
moi ce qui me manquait de ce qui me
manquait par exemple dans ensuite
j'avais quelqu'un de Montpellier où il
leur manque des anti-inflammatoires il
manque de la pranax et il manque
beaucoup d'antibiotiques et en fait ils
utilisent un antibiotique enfin ils
utilisent entre guillemets le stock
d'antibiotiques est passé donc il passe
sur un authentibiotique et pas et puis
évidemment tout les stocks sont sont
épuisés et on se retrouve avec pas grand
chose les doses les dosages d'enfants
ont été
refait avec des dosages adultes et c'est
vrai que c'est assez compliqué je pense
à mes amis pharmaciens effectivement qui
sont obligés de faire du travail
supplémentaire et et c'est vrai que des
les
patients sont conscients mais c'est pour
eux ça leur pose aussi un problème en
disant est-ce que c'est le bon
médicament est-ce que comment ils
veulent prendre parce que c'est vrai que
l'antibiotique chez l'enfant
l'antibiotique a un drôle de goût un
mauvais goût et c'est vrai que chez
l'enfant quand on met des
mais il est vrai que quelque part c'est
quelque chose qui est embêtant pour pour
une et donc ça c'est important et puis
on a une hiérarchisation c'est des
médicaments donc effectivement
l'antibiotique l'Empire antipyrétique
c'est important mais il y a aussi des
médicaments qui sont indispensables aux
gens et si on était en rupture ça serait
vraiment très très ennuyeux je pense aux
anticoagulants à tous les traitements
effectivement neurologiques tous les
traitements psychotes psychotropes tous
les traitements d'insuline dans
hypertenseurs et tous les traitements
d'urgence et donc ça il faut faire très
attention parce que pour nous en fait
quelquefois on n'a aucun équivalent donc
en fait c'est faire prendre des risques
faire prendre des risques à des gens
donc voilà un petit peu les choses que
je voulais dire parce que je voulais que
ça soit pratique ou pratique parce que
tout le reste ça a été plus ou moins dit
à certains à tous les niveaux donc c'est
vrai qu'on est on est vraiment en phase
de nos patients quand on sait qu'il y a
une rupture donc on fait on essaie de
palier tout de suite et puis quand il y
a pas de rupture ben c'est nos confrères
enfin Mazda qui nous appellent on dit
embar qu'est-ce que j'y mets qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et donc on essaie de faire
je vais pas dire de la débrouille mais
effectivement faire ce qu'on a quoi
voilà merci beaucoup
docteur Coulon
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs au
niveau de médecins pour demain on a eu
pour rejoindre un peu le les propos qui
ont déjà été dit pas mal de remontées
sur les ruptures de médicaments en
premier lieu les antibiotiques en
premier les antibiotiques pour les
enfants
notamment avec les flacons en verre qui
ont été problématiques à fournir la
deuxième remontée qu'on a eu c'est les
corticoïdes et notamment qui ont posé
des problèmes pour les maladies
auto-immunes et les ruptures dans les
suivis de maladies auto-immune troisième
problème les sirops antitussifs vont
c'est un peu moins grave les
anticoagulants ça a été dit au premier
des rangs desquels larixtra qu'on
utilise beaucoup comme dans les
phlébites et les embolies pulmonaires
l'axilocaïne la exécoline qui a un gel
qu'on utilise pour donc anesthésiser
donc ça posait problème pour des futurs
ça a posé des problèmes aussi pour les
mises en place de d'implants dans les
suites d'IVG
le paracétamol ça a été dit et y compris
le paracétamol associé à la codéine ont
posé aussi pas mal de problèmes plus
grave les médicaments portaient un
diabète
pénurie d'insuline rapide et plus lente
des médicaments comme le gène humet
level Messia et le cas particulier le
zampier que l'on lance en pic c'est un
peu particulier ce que c'est un
médicament très prescrit dans le monde
qui a été détourné pour les régimes dans
les dans les réseaux sociaux du type Tik
Tok et ça a posé des problèmes
d'approvisionnement dans le monde entier
à cause de ça
pour d'autres médicaments les
immunothérapies les protocoles de
désensibilisation pour les allergies ont
dû être interrompues parfois les
antimigraineuses a été dit les vaccins
hépatite B zona méningite le rotarisme
pour les gastro-entérites du nourrisson
les piliers labortives alors ça c'était
un problème notamment be the one utilisé
dans les IVG médicamenteuses donc pas
possibilité de faire des IVG
médicamenteuses les médicaments utilisés
en psychiatrie c'était déjà un peu dit
la mythalediazépam les chimiothérapie
qui ont dû être décalées
y compris à l'hôpital Saint-Louis à
Paris moi signalé par exemple et enfin
le dernier qui m'a été remonté c'est les
pistolets pour les biopsites prostate
deux mois de mois de décalage avant de
dépister un cancer de la prostate
donc tout ça effectivement ça crée des
problèmes notamment pour les
antibiotiques ça a été galère pour les
pour les patients certains ont rapporté
des des gens de leur famille ont ramené
des médicaments antibiotiques du Maroc
ou d'Israël ou du Portugal donc depuis
étrangers
et ont passé parfois plusieurs heures en
éclusant 4 5 6 pharmacies des fois
plusieurs kilomètres pour trouver les
médicaments
voilà je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour cette état ce tour
d'horizon de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain donc
Laurence Cohen première salle de
question oui mais merci pour pour avoir
ciblé en fait
sur les pénuries ce que vous vivez en
tant que en tant que praticien
et ce qui corrobore ce que nous avons pu
entendre depuis le début de nos
auditions ce que nous avons également
entendu c'est la difficulté le manque
d'information en fait des médecins sur
les pénuries de médicaments et
ce qui nous a été dit c'est que souvent
ces informations en fait elles vous sont
donnés par les pharmaciens qui eux donc
sont ceux qui vous alertent sur les les
pénuries donc mes questions là-dessus
c'est est-ce que d'abord ce problème
d'information
représente de la même manière en ville
et à l'hôpital
comment les médecins finalement
pourraient être mieux informés
contenu des difficultés que vous avez pu
nous décrire est-ce que vous avez
justement dans ce domaine-là des
recommandations dont nous sommes
preneurs concernant une meilleure
information quand nous avons rencontré
la Haute Autorité de Santé donc lors de
notre de nos auditions il nous a été
indiqués que la HAS contribuait à
relayer notamment les recommandations
qui étaient faites par la l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament au
médecin en affichant
des messages dans des dans des logiciels
d'aide à la à la prescription donc
j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous dire
d'abord si ces logiciels
vous conviennent si vous y accès
facilement si c'est encore un surcroît
de travail de temps de temps dépenser si
c'est suffisant etc qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez et puis vous en avez un petit
peu parlé mais du coup là peut-être
vous aurez un peu plus de temps pour
nous donner des éléments plus plus
complets la NSM effectivement fait des
recommandations qui visent à adapter les
prescriptions
en proposant des réductions des durées
de traitement des substitutions de
médicaments comme vous avez pu le dire
Madame et ça a été notamment le cas plus
récemment l'hiver dernier avec
l'amoxicilline donc est-ce que vous
trouvez que c'est un accompagnement
suffisant vous en tant que prescripteur
nous savons que vous avez des dialogues
permanents avec les pharmaciens qui vous
appellent
justement quand il y a rupture et quand
il doit ils peuvent substituer les
médicaments pour que ça soit vraiment un
dialogue constructif dans l'intérêt du
patient qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez et qu'est-ce qui pourrait là
encore être mieux adapté à votre
pratique et aux besoins de vos patients
toujours la NSM nous a également
souligné un rôle important en France de
la surconsommation de médicaments dans
les difficultés
d'approvisionnement et ce qui pourrait
expliquer en partie le phénomène de
pénurie notamment en France qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que
effectivement les Françaises et les
Français sont des grands consommateurs
de médicaments et comment vous vous
voyez les choses donc puisque il
pourrait y avoir aussi un travail de
prévention d'information des patients
pour pour remédier
est-ce que vous pensez les les parce que
c'est multifactoriel les pénuries de
médicaments les ruptures de stock et du
coup les réponses sont aussi
multifactorielles on nous a parlé parmi
les solutions qui pourraient être
envisagées
l'extension de la date de péremption des
médicaments en tension est-ce que
ça vous paraît quelque chose de possible
et ce qu'au contraire ça aurait une
incidence sur les faits thérapeutiques
du dit médicament et que ça ne serait
pas souhaitable et puis la dernière
question d'ailleurs elle vous a été
posée dans son propos introductif par la
rapporteur
dans l'adaptation pas la rapporteur la
présidente puisque voilà rapporteur et
confusion des gens c'est la fatigue mais
dans quelle mesure l'adaptation des
prescriptions du fait des pénuries de
médicaments vous paraissent justement
renforcer les risques diatrogéniques et
les risques de surdosage que ce soit en
ville ou à l'hôpital et du coup comment
ce risque peut-il être maîtrisé
voilà je vous remercie
je vous laisse répondre dans l'ordre que
vous souhaitez si je peux répondre sur
la consommation des médicaments c'était
un sujet qui m'a interpellé avec le
passage le directeur de la CNAM devant
vous là et à propos des antibiotiques
il y a volume d'un côté volume de
prescription antibiotique donc les
prescriptions il y a aussi la
consommation des antibiotiques et ces
deux choses très différentes
déjà par rapport au volume il faut
rajouter en plus de volume la qualité
c'est à dire qu'actuellement les
médecins français sont en médecine de
ville les parmi les meilleurs d'Europe
en termes de prescription de qualité de
l'antibiotiques je m'explique
ce qui fait la résistance aux
antibiotiques et un sujet majeur qui
émerge de plus en plus dans le monde
c'est la prescription des antibiotiques
à large spectre et en Europe il y a un
ratio qui a été fait au niveau de la
jante des agences européennes pour
calculer le ratio médicament large
spectre et médicaments à spectre étroit
plus se rassurer moins c'est bon plus il
est bas mieux meilleur c'est en France
le ratio est de 1 pour la médecine de
ville c'est un des meilleurs de en
Europe
en Allemagne il y a de 1,6 en Belgique
1,9 en Italie la 8,3 et ça va jusqu'à
20,7 je crois en Hongrie
les seuls pays à mieux moins faire mieux
que en France c'est en Scandinavie c'est
la Suède le Danemark et puis la Finlande
avec 0,3 mais nous avec un on est
vraiment dans les meilleurs donc la
qualité de ce qu'on prescrit en ville
elle est bonne après je vous parlais
consommation pourquoi parler de
consommation et pas de prescription je
crois que le santé publique France
s'intéresse surtout à la prescription
des médecins uniquement à ça dans le
dans le comptage des antibiotiques mais
l'OMS a émis une alerte au mois de
novembre dernier pour l'Europe ils ont
fait une étude sur la consommation des
antibiotiques et un tiers de la
consommation des antibiotiques se fait
en dehors de toute prescription ce qui
est énorme
par trois biens le premier biais c'est
les antibiotiques qui restent dans les
boîtes qui n'ont pas été utilisés alors
dans la famille chez les amis chez les
voisins etc hop au taux prescription et
ça se voit en France de plus en plus je
sais pas ce qu'on pense mais mes
confrères de plus en plus on va arriver
des gens disent j'ai fini la boîte
d'antibiotique il me restait de la
dernière fois j'ai attaqué un traitement
il faudrait me donner la suite donc ça
c'est une première réalité la deuxième
réalité donc une solution qui pourrait
être proposée en France ça serait de
donner les antibiotiques à l'unité ça
serait quand même mieux
la deuxième le deuxième problématique
c'est l'accès direct aux antibiotiques
hors ordonnances en pharmacie donc là la
l'étude qui avait fait l'OMS dans
certains pays il y avait un accès direct
et en France on introduit récemment dans
la loi la possibilité d'accéder direct
pour la prescription de l'antibiotique
dans les pharmacies pour les infections
urinaires et puis pour les angines c'est
passé dans la loi je sais pas si c'est
encore en décret d'application mais ça
évoque un risque d'explosion de la
consommation des antibiotiques parce que
les gens vont aller faire la pression
chez les pharmaciens en disant moi même
chose mon antibiotique donnez-le moi il
risque d'y avoir un rapport de force qui
avait montré l'OMS c'est le troisième
c'est le
c'est Internet et l'achat des
médicaments sur internet alors j'ai pas
trouvé statistique en France la dernière
statistique que j'avais c'est 2011 et en
2011 il y avait 10 millions 400 000
Français qui avaient acheté des
médicaments sur Internet la consommation
actuelle le mode de consommation du
médicament et de la consommation des
soins en France a considérablement
changé en disant je pense ça a dû
évoluer mais ça c'est aussi une
préoccupation
et donc par rapport à ça
il y a une thèse qui avait été faite par
à Caen qui s'appelle de quelqu'un qui
s'appelle trampoline Morisset qui disait
pour réduire la prescription
d'antibiotiques pour du réduire la
consommation et pour qu'il y ait une
acceptation des gens pour prendre moins
d'antibiotique il faut de la prévention
et de l'éducation donc il faut dégager
du temps
un médecin pour demain nous c'est notre
light motif c'est à dire que on
porte la consultation à 50 euros mais
pourquoi on porte la caution à 50 euros
pas pour changer rien changé au système
c'est pour doubler le temps de
consultation 2 x 10 minutes ça fait 20
minutes je remets le cadre on est sur
les pénuries de médicaments oui
mais pour diminuer la pénurie de
médicaments pour diminuer la
prescription et l'acceptation de pas
donner d'antibiotiques ça nécessite du
temps
et si vous voulez vous avez actuellement
la sécurité sociale voudrait nous
pousser à prendre plus de passion et
donc à quelque part raccourcir la durée
de consultation et nous on souhaite
l'exacte inverse dans un cadre de
prévention c'est très important parce
qu'il y a que comme ça qu'on arrivera à
convaincre les gens de prendre de pas
prendre l'antibiotique et de diminuer
indirectement et la prescription
d'antibiotiques et l'acceptation de la
non prescription et donc le volume
d'antibiotique prescrit et donc quelque
part sur la pénurie de médicaments
résoudre au moins ce problème là en
partie ce qu'il faut savoir dernier
point c'est que 60% des tuyaux OMS
montraient que 60% des gens
étaient persuadés que les antibiotiques
étaient efficaces contre les virus en
France c'est 52% qui croisent ce qui est
énorme il y a un gros gros boulot à
faire voilà je vous remercie
merci
oui donc il y a beaucoup de choses qui
ont été dites mais ce que je voulais
rajouter quand même effectivement
l'éducation thérapeutique de du patient
c'est énorme énormément c'est vrai quand
on commence à s'installer ça fait plus
de 30 ans d'envoyer un peu de bouteille
on l'a les patients qui effectivement on
les amène petit à petit à pas prendre
n'importe quoi à pas faire de
l'automédication à pouvoir savoir quand
il faut venir quand il faut pas venir
donc ça c'est déjà un premier chose
après l'antibiotique c'est pas
automatique ça a fait énormément de bien
aussi pour que les gens prennent
conscience de ça et je pense qu'il
faudrait le refaire parce que ça c'est
hyper important parce qu'on le voit et
malheureusement le voit de plus en plus
maintenant avec la téléconsultation et
donc pour nous c'est un énorme problème
parce que dans les téléconsultations on
examine pas les gens donc on fait un
large spectre donc on met des
antibiotiques largamanu de la cortisone
des choses comme ça alors qu'on a pas vu
les gens les a pas ausculté et je suis
une clinicienne enfin qui qui vraiment
il tient et je pense qu'effectivement ça
c'est quelque chose d'important parce
qu'on a vu beaucoup beaucoup de de
passer en revenir avec les ordonnances
effectivement où c'est marqué
qu'ils ont pris de l'antibiotique de la
cortisone et autres et donc ça c'est
quand même pas normal parce que ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure par rapport à ça
quand c'est un problème ORL il y a les
trottes qui existent et ça ça permet
déjà de faire un bon un bon choix quoi
et donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'important qu'il faut qu'il faut
marquer l'autre chose aussi qui est
importante effectivement la prévention
mais la prévention on l'a vu avec le
covid ou on était un petit peu moins en
contact les uns avec les autres c'est un
peu plus laver les mains et on cracha je
sais pas sur les autres quand on avait
quand on avait des problèmes donc je
pense qu'il faudrait aussi rappeler ça
et le rappeler les plus jeune âge
c'est-à-dire que nous à l'école
maternelle on nous apprenait à nous
laver les mains on allait pas manger à
la cantine sur le constatent les mâles
maintenant c'est complètement les salles
abondance la même les dents après
d'ailleurs mais c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'il faut remettre au goût
du jour et dès le plus jeune âge parce
qu'effectivement apprendre à vivre
apprendre à pouvoir se servir de la
médecine c'est quelque chose d'important
parce qu'il y a une pénurie de tout en
ce moment en médecine des médicaments
mais des médecins des professionnels de
santé de tout de tout donc là il faut
apprendre à
pouvoir faire tout cela l'autre chose
aussi enfin c'est tous les effets
secondaires qu'on peut voir avec parce
qu'effectivement avant les génériques le
reconnaissait les médicaments en disant
cette petite rose qui a marqué à r
dessus c'est le petit jaune c'est le
petit truc est ovale maintenant tout est
blanc et donc en fait il peut y avoir
aussi des mélanges donc il faut faire
très attention avec tous ces mélanges
parce que des fois les gens ils prennent
deux fois le même traitement sans se
rendre compte que c'est la même chose et
donc ça c'est encore autre chose et donc
quand on prend deux fois la même chose
évidemment on a deux fois plus de chance
de manquer de médicaments ultérieurement
l'autre chose c'est les interactions
médicamenteuses et des médicaments qu'on
peut absolument pas mélanger les uns
avec les autres et donc faut être très
vigilant parce que parce que il faut pas
il faut pas provoquer des effets qui
soient plus toxiques que ce que ce qu'on
veut régler comme problème
l'autre chose quelque part c'est vrai
qu'avec avec un peu de bouteille on a vu
que les problèmes sont arrivés un petit
peu avec avec les génériques parce qu'en
fait les génériques
les prix sont un peu faibles donc je
pense qu'il y a aussi ce problème là
mais un autre problème c'est qu'en fait
on se rend compte que les doses de
péremption des génériques sont beaucoup
plus faibles que les que les princesses
et donc quelquefois oui et quelquefois
on voyait des médicaments qui en fait
avaient un
comment attendre de péremption qui
paraissait vraiment court par rapport
aux princesses mais bon ça va peut-être
changer là depuis mais parce qu'en fait
c'est des gens qui nous amènent les deux
pour demander si c'est la même chose
donc on se rend compte mais mais
peut-être à vérifier ce à vérifier cela
donc les champions de la table de
péremption on n'est pas fermé on n'est
pas pharmacien et on a des difficultés à
vous pouvoir vous répondre donc ça c'est
quelque chose de je réponds que ce que
je peux savoir et encore je fais pas
tout et plus j'essaie d'apprendre et moi
je sais donc ça c'est important et donc
ça c'est par rapport au nombre de
comprimés par rapport aux boîtes on a vu
quand même maintenant il y a de plus en
plus de médicaments ou on a la
possibilité d'avoir pour trois jours
pour 5 jours et donc ça c'est quand même
bien il y a moins de perte parce
qu'effectivement c'est c'est tous ces
problèmes là qui qui était d'actualité
et c'est vrai que quelque part aussi
c'est de savoir exactement enfin quand
il reste quand les gens ont commencé un
médicament puis qui dit ça me va pas et
les boîtes sont jetées qu'est-ce qu'on
peut on pourrait peut-être en faire
quelque chose suite à temps les
récupérer maintenant on récupère plutôt
mais c'est vrai que
nous en tant que médecin quand on quand
on avait dans le temps des possibilités
d'avoir des des boîtes de médicaments on
tournait toujours avec des boîtes pour
pouvoir dépanner les gens le soir pour
éviter d'avoir justement cette rupture
de stock
surtout cette non prise en charge rapide
de nos patients tout à l'heure vous
parliez par rapport au fait de savoir si
on les médicaments si on peut savoir moi
il y a que mon pharmacien enfin mes
pharmaciens parce qu'on a plusieurs et
on s'entend tous bien qui peuvent me
dire ce qu'il y a en stock ou pas parce
que vous voyez tout à l'heure je vous
dis j'appelais quelqu'un d'autre et en
fait c'est pas les mêmes médicaments qui
sont en rupture de stock à notre endroit
de la France donc en fait on est c'est
vraiment très ponctuel mais ça rejoint
un petit peu quand on était de garde il
y a quelques années où on a tous des
habitudes de prescription qui fait qu'en
fait les pharmaciens en général ils
regardaient toujours qui était de garde
le week-end et commander les médicaments
pour pas être en rupture de stock et
donc ça c'est c'est vraiment des choses
effectivement on le voit un petit peu
avec nos pharmaciens qui effectivement
vont pas acheter des trucs qui vont pas
vendre parce que ça sera pas prescrit
donc donc revoir un petit peu tout ça
donc si vous voulez c'est du sur mesure
et c'est d'ailleurs c'est ça la médecine
c'est pas du prêt-à-porter c'est du
sur-mesure et donc il faut vraiment que
ça que ça soit pérennisé et qu'on voit
un petit peu en face attention mais
faire attention aux interactions
médicamenteuses et puis à tout ce qui
est surdosage parce qu'effectivement les
gens ils ont l'habitude de prendre
certains médicaments et et pas d'autres
et donc faut faire attention et après il
y a aussi tous les choses qu'on voit que
des médicaments ils sont peut-être les
mêmes choses à l'intérieur mais il y a
des il y a des excipients qui sont qui
sont qui peuvent leur être mauvais ou
des colorants qui peuvent être mauvais
donc ça faut faire très attention voilà
ce que j'avais à dire pour l'instant
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup docteur
perrouty
oui merci madame la Présidente
pour revenir sur le problème des
logiciels que vous avez évoqué dans
votre propos je crois que c'est vrai
qu'il y a un problème de géant on a des
logiciels à la prescription qui sont
assez pertinent j'en ai utilisé deux
successivement le Vidal et Claude
Bernard
[Musique]
et ces logiciels fonctionnent bien mais
justement il n'y a pas d'alerte alors il
y a des alertes il y a des messages qui
sont envoyés mais ces messages envoyés
on a les oublie par contre si au moment
où on prescrit il y avait un système qui
bloquait notre médicament utilisent
rupture en direct c'est pas compliqué
avec de l'informatique ça nous aiderait
beaucoup parce qu'effectivement si on
prescrit ce médicament le patient va
aller à la pharmacie le pharmacien veut
dire il y est pas alors parfois il a le
temps de nous mais pas toujours en plus
que standard sont saturés donc il
n'arrive pas à nous avoir c'est le
patient qui va nous revenir nous voir il
y a un délai entre la prescription et le
remplacement du médicament qui est quand
même problématique et c'est vrai que là
on pourrait sûrement jouer sur un
logiciel de la prescription que
maintenant la plupart des médecins ont
puisque ça fait partie d'ailleurs du
volet rémunération sur objectif de santé
publique de forfait structure et ça
serait une très bonne chose et ça on
pourrait demander aux éditeurs de
logiciels de le faire je crois que un
deuxième parce que
le remplacement du médicament non
disponible si il y a une immersive dans
le système qui est quand même vraiment
délétère
autre élément c'est la consommation des
médicaments alors pourquoi ils sont en
rupture de stock ça il faut j'ai pas la
réponse à tout mais on sait bien qu'il y
a des problèmes de fabrication parce
qu'on nous dit il y a des matières
premières manquantes pour certains
médicaments donc ça c'est une vraie
problématique et c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure la relocaliser sur des
fabrications est-ce qu'il y a des
matières premières importantes qu'il
faudrait sécuriser mais il y a en même
temps sur des ruptures il y a la
consommation j'allais dire inappropriée
alors on dit le trop de prescription il
y a aussi surtout en France sauf
erreur de ma part je pense qu'il y a à
peu près 50% des médicaments qui sont
pas consommés ils sont prescrits mais
pas consommés alors ça coûte très cher
mais aussi pareil ils sont plus
disponibles pour être consommés par des
gens qui en auraient besoin et ça c'est
une vraie réflexion qu'il faut amener
enfin ça fait longtemps qu'on le sait
mais comment faire en sorte que on ne
distribue pas des médicaments que le
patient c'est pertinemment qui va pas
utiliser parce qu'il le sait souvent les
patients nous le disent mais non
monsieur village de supporte pas mais on
leur a distribué à la pharmacie parce
qu'ils ont rien dit souvent
je leur demande leurs ordonnances en
passion je le vois en neurologie et puis
comme quand je vois l'ordonnance
la moitié
on est dans une situation qui arrive
qu'il faudrait corriger parce que ça va
moi je me donne une anecdote
on vient de d'accueillir chez nous mon
beau-père 92 ans il vivait avec ma
belle-mère 96 ans Alzheimer lui
Parkinson on a retrouvé sans boîte de
doliprane chez eux
c'est vous dire et c'était distribué
régulièrement parce que vous regardez
les ordonnances souvent il y a écrit 6
douleurs doliprane un comprimé trois
fois par jour et puis ça repart de moi
en moi et voilà donc ça c'est quand même
des à la fois les logiciels qui
pourraient nous avertir beaucoup plus
vite et la délivrance de médicaments de
façon vraiment
utile dans ce qui va être consommé et
puis le dernier point c'est la
fabrication pour éviter
des ruptures d'approvisionnement avec ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure aussi
la question qu'il faut se poser est-ce
qu'il y a des médicaments qui sont
disponibles et qui s'est réorienté vers
d'autres pays d'Europe à cause du tarif
des médicaments nous on l'a vécu pendant
très longtemps je peux vous le dire en
neurologie sur des médicaments
essentiels sclérose en plaques dans les
épilepsie et quand on appelait le
laboratoire fabricant il nous est
médicament est disponible il est parti
en Belgique en Allemagne je sais pas où
parce que le médicament est plus
rémunérateur pour le grossiste et donc
on était en octobre puisque là aussi ma
part on attribue une quantité de
laboratoire à tribune quantité à un
grossiste et s'il grossiste il en fait
partir une partie ailleurs c'est plus là
pour les patients français
j'avais juste une remarque juste une
remarque Par rapport donc aux
médicaments non utilisés où il y avait
une étude aux États-Unis qui montrait
que 30% des médicaments prescrits
finissaient la poubelle
30%. donc un tiers ce qui est énorme et
effectivement il y a tout un travail de
prévention à faire toujours la
prévention toujours le temps nécessaire
à consacrer au patients et la
polymédiation des personnes âgées c'est
un vrai problème parce qu'il se retrouve
souvent au-delà de 65 70 ans avec 8 10
12 médicaments à prendre voire plus
qu'est-ce qui se passe en fait comme la
médecine se complexifie vous avez un
problème de coeur vous allez mettre vous
allez mettre les médicaments qui sont le
référentiel pour les pathologies
cardiaques maladie de reins pareil un
diplôme millionnaire et en fait vous
faites à chaque fois dans chaque
spécialité le meilleur traitement
possible sans tenir compte des
interactions entre chacune des
spécialités chacune des organes
et après
et après on finit par avoir des gens
donc ils font des hypothensions des
chutes des retours à l'hôpital etc et
donc ça un coup qui a été évalué de
l'ordre de 3500 euros par patient vous
pouvez m'indiquer ce qui est énorme les
sources d'économie et de gâcher de
médicaments sont très importantes
voilà
ce carburant
non je pense que tout a été dit il y a
juste une question sur la recrudescence
en fait de des maladies chroniques et du
vieillissement de la population face à
la pénurie dont on n'a pas la réponse
aussi enfin de sur le futur en fait
merci beaucoup j'ai passé la parole à
mes collègues donc j'ai Alexandra
Chaudfontaine
merci Madame le présidente mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs merci
pour les informations que vous nous
délivrez en fait c'est un peu le serpent
qui se mord la queue finalement parce
que on a l'impression en tout cas en
tant que patient que plus il va y avoir
de la pénurie bah plus on a envie de
faire des stocks je pense que c'est un
comportement qui peut se reproduire dans
d'autres domaines je pense notamment
l'alimentation et c'est pour ça qu'il y
a autant de d'initiatives contre le
gaspillage alimentaire donc
l'objectif en tout cas de cette audition
aujourd'hui c'était essayer de de savoir
en tout cas pour ma part quelles étaient
les pistes que vous pourriez préconiser
pour réduire justement cet écart entre
la prescription et la consommation alors
on a parlé bien sûr de refaire une
campagne de communication sur notamment
les antibiotiques ou parlez tout à
l'heure docteur de prescrire un
médicament enfin le nombre de
médicaments
limité quoi donc voilà je voulais juste
en fait vous interroger pour savoir
est-ce que vous avez davantage de pistes
qui pourraient être mis en place pour
finalement essayer justement de changer
les comportements bien sûr il y a la
prévention au cas par cas c'est ce que
vous demandiez aussi vis-à-vis de votre
passion mais voilà on a l'impression moi
j'ai l'impression en tout cas que il
existe pas vraiment une solution
miracle par rapport à ça et que plus il
y aura de pénurie et plus on se les gens
ont envie de de constituer des stocks
alors heureusement
je dis pas que c'est une généralité je
voilà je sais pas en fait finalement si
on va réussir à trouver une solution
donc
je vais compléter par les questions de
mes collègues Pascal grenier
oui merci moi je reviens sur sur la
surconsommation d'ailleurs monsieur
carvalero dans votre introduction vous
aviez dit qu'il y a pas de
surconsommation moi je remercie parce
que quand même là vous avez donné
quelques éléments je sais plus qui sur
l'accès direct en pharmacie bon nous
c'est vrai que ici au Sénat dans sa
majorité on essaie de de préserver le
médecin et l'accès direct le moins
possible parce que le diagnostic la
responsabilité elle est toujours sur le
médecin quand même donc il faut quand
même faire attention mais bon on sait
que on le fait de temps en temps
sur les médicaments qui n'ont pas été
consommés oui sur le comment samedi il y
avait quelqu'un la radio justement alors
je sais plus c'était présidente et
pharmaciens ou sur les médicaments à
l'unité et en fait ils expliquaient que
c'était très très compliqué à
l'expliquer que c'était très compliqué
elle avait donné un tas d'éléments
justement sur ça je pense que si c'était
simple on l'aurait on l'aurait déjà fait
parce que ça fait des je sais pas 10 ans
15 ans que qu'on en parle donc si ça a
pas été fait je pense que c'est quand
même compliqué et les achats internet
moi je dis juste que les Français sont
fous d'aller acheter sur internet des
médicaments ou on sait pas du tout du
tout comment ça va se passer
donc ceci dit pour les antibiotiques
quand même moi je te vois dans
l'entourage les gens ils sont sous
antibiotiques pour un oui pour un nom
personnellement je me soignée en
homéopathie et mon médecin homéopathe me
donner évent me prescrivez
éventuellement de temps en temps les
antibiotiques quand il fallait
aujourd'hui j'ai pu le médecin
homéopathe donc qu'est-ce que j'ai j'ai
le médecin qui lui n'a pas d'autre
solution en fait quand je vais le voir
que de me passer sous antibiotique alors
qu'auparavant je sortais pas avec une
ordonnance d'antibiotiques ma fille est
au Luxembourg
c'est je veux dire quelqu'un qui est
assez fragile elle est pratiquement
jamais sous antibiotique en revanche
elle fait des tests en Chine des choses
comme ça régulièrement donc quand elle
nous voit nous et Pascal revient chez
nous elle va voir les médecins aussi de
temps en temps pour les enfants etc et
elle me dit franchement chez nous c'est
l'antibiotique c'est vraiment voilà
l'ultime solution quand on va voir quand
on a
je sais pas en tous etc donc je pense
que quand même et vous avez dit Madame
qu'en fait
ce serait bien de faire un peu de
publicité sur les antibiotiques c'est
pas automatique et c'est vrai parce que
ça avait eu un effet certain parce que
les antibiotiques c'est bien mais au
bout d'un moment si on en consomme de
trop d'abord ils sont moins efficaces
c'est comme c'est comme tout et puis et
puis en plus ça soigne pas forcément en
fait c'est après c'est un aspect
psychologique et vous n'avez pas parlé
aussi dans dans cette surconsommation du
du tiers payant en fait on paye plus le
médicament c'est gratuit
donc ben voilà pourquoi pourquoi on en
consommerait pas après tout donc sur ces
sujets là voilà moi ce que je voulais
vous dire je pense quand même que chez
nous et vous avez parlé aussi des
psychotropes je crois quelqu'un des
médecins à parler des psychotropes là
aussi enfin on le voit partout dans
notre entourage partout où on va les
gens ils prennent toujours un truc pour
dormir pour les nerfs pour ceci pour
cela je dis pas que il en faut pas je
pense que le docteur sait quand est-ce
qu'il qu'il en faut et je crois que on
en prend sans penser des fois aussi aux
effets aux interactions avec d'autres
médicaments puis aussi quoi un
médicament c'est pas c'est pas
l'alimentation quoi
Laurence Muller Braun
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
et messieurs pour vos explications alors
je me dis en vous écoutant que
finalement c'est là on parle de la
pénurie des médicaments qui seraient le
fait d'une d'une surconsommation des
patients moi j'ai du mal à y croire
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a même si
elle existe j'ai du mal à penser que
c'est ce sont les patients qui font que
aujourd'hui on est en pénurie sur
certaines molécules et quelquefois sur
alors là on parle de médicaments que les
personnes peuvent prendre à la maison
mais dans toutes les auditions que nous
avons eu on a quand même parler de
pénurie et vous l'avez dit Monsieur dans
les listes des anticancer des
anticancéreux des des médicaments liés
vraiment à des maladies graves et là le
patient le consommateur il n'y est
absolument pour rien et ce sont ces
médicaments aussi qui sont en général
très coûteux on nous a parlé de mon
temps très important donc on peut dire
que
les Français se soigne trop qu'ils
chauffent trop qu'il se lavent trop
enfin vous savez on a tendance
aujourd'hui à mettre beaucoup de
responsabilités sur le dos des Français
mais là pour moi non il y a un autre
quel est votre votre idée là-dessus
cette pénurie elle existe sur des voilà
on a entendu les hôpitaux juste avant
vous là le consommateur il n'y est pour
rien le français n'est pour rien on va
le soigner avec les les médicaments ou
les traitements que l'hôpital peut
obtenir et il y a des soucis ils nous
l'ont confirmé et puis là c'est vous
avez aussi vécu quelque chose
d'exceptionnel j'ai l'impression ces
trois dernières années puisque on a vu
que vous aviez été en tant que médecin
interdit de prescrire ou interdit de
soigner donc c'était quelque chose je
voulais vous poser la question comment
vous avez compris cela quelles sont les
conséquences et qu'en pensez-vous merci
beaucoup
emiliane Pomerol
je vais aller tout à fait dans la ligne
de ma collègue à l'instant parce que
j'ai le sentiment alors à travers votre
expérience j'allais dire au quotidien de
professionnelle de santé qu'on est en
train de détourner un petit peu le sujet
qui est quand même la pénurie de
médicaments et la stratégie de
l'industrie pharmaceutique en
culpabilisant un les médecins de les
patients alors on est tous d'accord sur
le succès de l'antibiotique c'est pas
automatique on est tous d'accord sur la
nécessité de la prévention de
l'éducation etc de la surconsommation
dans certains cas oui j'ai des médecins
généralistes et j'ai vu parfois
effectivement quand on ouvrait la
pharmacie du patient de dire ah mais il
vous reste encore deux si vous reste
encore de là mais c'est quand même à la
marge je crois pas que ce soit
l'essentiel du fond du problème et
j'aurais aimé vous entendre en tant que
prescripteur qui est au bout de la
chaîne effectivement
davantage sur les causes
vous analyser vous comme être
responsable j'allais dire de cette
pénurie ou de ces pénuries ou tensions
d'approvisionnement aujourd'hui dans
l'organisation de l'industrie du monde
industriel et dans l'organisation
ensuite de la distribution et aussi de
l'information parce qu'effectivement le
la solution des
salades grec de la chaise sur les sur
les logiciels bien sûr que serait une
aide pratique je veux dire si
effectivement comme on le disait notre
collègue neurologue au moment où on
prescrit on avait un ping ping ping une
alerte qui dit rupture de stock ça
permettrait d'éviter mais là on est en
bout de chaîne on est à la fin du
problème ce qui nous intéresserait c'est
très intéressant de vous nous donniez
votre expérience au quotidien mais votre
analyse personnelle aussi en tant
qu'utilisateur j'allais dire de du
médicament sur les causes profondes de
ce cette situation aujourd'hui qui a
évolué de façon exponentielle depuis 10
ans
très bien donc je voulais vous la
réponse docteur Colomb après docteur le
soudeur
industries du médicament les industries
du médicament au niveau des grands
groupes pharmaceutiques mondiaux et
intervient ils investissent actuellement
dans les domaines les plus lucratifs
cancer immunologie vaccin
et également les maladies neurologiques
ma part qui sonne et puis maladie
d'Alzheimer ça ça rapporte beaucoup ils
ont délégué les médicaments peu
rentables aux autres notamment au
génériqueurs et
en France le problème particulier de la
France en plus du reste c'est que on a
des prix des médicaments qui sont parmi
les plus bas d'Europe 10 à 30% en
dessous les prix moyen européens donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe en fait au niveau
de ces médicaments là il y a des
grossistes qu'on appelle des shortliners
donc des shortliners comme le l'Europe
est un marché libre ils prennent les
médicaments à bas prix en France pour
aller les exporter ailleurs en Europe
les rendre plus cher donc ça c'est aussi
un des biais de du marché du médicament
qui a à bas prix qui atteint ses limites
et qui pose un vrai problème si pour
s'en sortir par rapport à la pénible
médicament si on investissent pas
massivement dans l'industrie au niveau
européen au niveau français notamment
dans l'industrie des vaccins
et bien on va confronter de plus en plus
à des pénuries massives parce que la
logique du médicament à moindre coût
elle atteint ses limites c'est comme la
médecine à bas coût et latin se limite à
l'heure actuelle aussi donc
sinon sur les antibiotiques et nous qui
arrivons l'idée d'arriver en deuxième
ligne par rapport aux antibiotiques je
vais prendre l'exemple des infections
urinaires oui ça pourrait être une
solution de dire bon ben une cystite
simple on va voir le pharmacien et puis
voilà quoi
l'idéal l'idéal à ce moment-là c'est que
le pharmacien donne pas d'antibiotique
mais des mécaniques phytothérapie pour
traiter la cystite simple ou des
anti-inflammatoires il y a des études
notamment en Allemagne qui ont été
faites qui montrent qu'effectivement il
y a 50% de succès
mais 50% d'échec fatalement mais ça fait
50% d'antibiotiques donnés en moins le
problème c'est qu'actuellement niveau
international on manque d'études pour
l'impact de la phytothérapie l'avait
fait réel de cette phytothérapie sur la
prescription des antibiotiques mais on
pourrait très bien construire un système
avec les pharmaciens première ligne
phytothérapie et nous après pour les
toutes les cystites non simples fébrile
etc on intervient en seconde ligne et là
on traite c'est pareil on n'a pas
d'intérêt non plus on a une technicité
qui est importante en tant que médecin
voir des gens pour un arrêt de travail
d'un jour deux jours trois jours ça
aucun intérêt recentrer le médecin
autour de ces vrais tâches c'est
fondamental effectivement on pourrait
dégager du temps médical en ne
ressentrant sur les tâches les plus
complexes mais l'idée oui l'idée de
moins prescrire d'antibiotiques et pas
si simple que ça
si ce n'est de dégager pour l'instant du
temps au niveau des cabinets médicaux du
temps médical pour expliquer aux gens
pourquoi on leur prescrit pas si on leur
explique pas qu'on fait des
consultations de tendues de 10 minutes
ils vont aller voir un autre médecin qui
va leur prescrire et donc on n'aura
jamais de solution
merci
Docteur le soudeur
oui beaucoup de questions de poser c'est
merci de les avoir posé j'ai pris
quelques notes parce que donc concernant
le stock quand c'est quelque chose
d'aiguë toute façon on peut pas faire de
stock ou alors effectivement on va
servir des médicaments qui a déjà été
prescrit avant et donc ça c'est pas
c'est d'automédication et ça là quelque
part le fait d'avoir des boîtes de 40 et
on en prend 10 ça fait 30 comprimés
d'avance et donc les enfants ce qu'ils
veulent malheureusement et comme
maintenant on est tous docteurs en
lisant internet ben on s'automédique
donc ça c'est un gros problème
l'autre chose ouais des stocks après
pour le stock de maladie chronique
l'intérêt d'ailleurs à avoir un tout
petit peu de stock parce que le temps
d'obtenir un rendez-vous pour avoir un
renouvellement de traitement et de
revoir son patient
ça permettrait un petit peu depuis voir
dans l'urgence des gens qui manquent de
médicaments ça ça serait déjà quelque
chose d'important néanmoins le stock
c'est je trouve que le stock c'est
plutôt le stock en amont plutôt que le
stock chez dans la pharmacie du passé en
quoi c'est-à-dire que le problème
effectivement c'est que en France et je
l'ai connu parce qu'à Montargis c'était
la dernière dernière comment fabrication
pour le paracétamol qui a fermé il y a
quelques années et en fait on était par
elle était content parce qu'on avait du
paracétamol à côté et donc c'était on
produisait maintenant il y a plus rien
qui est produit en France et que faut
faire attention quoi c'est à dire
qu'effectivement c'est 80% des des
principes ceux qui sont fabriqués en
Inde et en Chine donc après qu'est-ce
qui fabrique les médicaments c'est
encore du bacous c'est encore de la
rentabilité et c'est vrai qu'on a
ras-le-bol la médecine c'est pas de la
abilité quoi la médecine c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est pas un bien de
consommation la médecine le médicament
non plus et donc ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il faudrait peut-être rappeler parce
qu'effectivement le un comprimé c'est
pas c'est pas un bonbon quoi et quel que
soit sa couleur et quel que soit son
goût et donc ça c'est quelque chose de
très important et ça je pense
qu'effectivement dans l'éducation c'est
quelque chose c'est quelque chose à dire
par rapport à la surconsommation
effectivement il y a de toute façon vous
aurez toujours des gens qui se sur
consomment de toute façon vous aurez
toujours des gens qui débordent on avait
aussi tous ces médicaments là où
effectivement on est en train de se
rendre compte qu'on a créé des
dépendances aussi parce que
effectivement à force de donner certains
médicaments il y a des gens qui sont
devenus accro et ça c'est un gros gros
problème la dépendance des médicaments
et là-dessus il faut être très vigilant
c'est à dire qu'en tant que médecin faut
quand même avoir fait pour faire de la
pharmacopéegie dans sa tête il faut
quand on voit un patient et qu'on lui
prescrit un antidépresseur faut savoir
pourquoi on le prescrit combien de temps
va le prescrire et le suivre et ça c'est
un problème de suivi aussi c'est à dire
que par exemple les antibiotiques moi
c'est vrai qu'il y a des patients c'est
vous les voyez ils tous mais bon ça pour
la soirée ils ont pas besoin
d'antibiotiques et vous savez
certainement toute façon dans huit jours
ils vont venir et de toute façon ils
auront une très grosse bronchite ils
auront une otite et donc ça n'ira pas
mais en même temps c'est après un
problème de confiance aussi à faire qui
fait qu'en fait effectivement on peut
prescrire en disant vous le prenez si
besoin et et en fait les gens ne
l'achètent pas et c'est vrai quand vous
avez acquis cette espèce de confiance
être patient et praticien c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'intéressant parce que
vraiment vous faites des économies vous
faites faire des économies monstrueuses
et les gens du coup consomment beaucoup
moins parce que reine de vous appeler
quand vous dites mais c'est pas grave et
de savoir effectivement enfin quand on a
une infection urinaire moi chaque fois
toutes les femmes qui font des
infections urinaires je leur montre
comment se comment faire le choc le
lombaire pour savoir s'il y a une pilule
des frites ou pas et donc ça c'est hyper
important parce que du coup elles disent
non c'est une infection urinaire banale
donc effectivement surtout medicap ou tu
pas et quand elle m'appelle en disant
vous savez vraiment
[Rires]
mais si vous voulez exactement mais ce
que je veux dire aussi c'est qu'il y a
des traitements qui sont après il y a
des complications et c'est là les
complications qui deviennent graves il
faut pas passer à côté donc ça c'est
vraiment des choses il faut rester très
vigilant et donc être en la
hiérarchisation aussi de la prescription
et donc ça c'est important et c'est vrai
que le problème aussi c'est parler du
tiers payant toute façon maintenant
c'est vrai que le problème de tout cela
c'est que plus personne il y a même plus
un prix sur un médicament c'est-à-dire
que même nous quand on prescrit on sait
pas combien on coûte en sachant qu'une
consultation c'est rien le prix d'une
consultation c'est rien c'est le prix de
toutes les prescriptions qui sont
importantes et c'est ça qu'il faudrait
peut-être voir aussi et reprendre aussi
dans l'éducation dans l'apprentissage
des médecins dans notre de notre façon
de faire parce que plus vous voulez plus
on nous demande d'aller vite et moi on
est pertinent et donc ça ça va pas ça
c'est vrai que le temps est important
pour expliquer on pense beaucoup de
temps à expliquer aux gens pourquoi on
leur donne pas d'antibiotiques pourquoi
on leur met pas d'antidépresseurs pour
qu'on les écoute et puis qu'en fait ils
nous disent ah bah ça va mieux docteur
combien de fois on a je peux pas laisser
partir on ouvre la porte ils saute sous
un camion et en fait on leur parlant en
prenant du temps et bien on arrive à
dire on se revoit quand ah bah quand
vous voulez bon ben je vous envoie la
semaine prochaine je vous envoie trois
jours et puis on en reparle et donc ça
ça évite de prendre des médicaments et
c'est hyper important et donc ça c'est
quelque chose d'important après par
rapport au refus de soigner de qu'on
puisse effectivement faire des soins
pendant le covid ça a été notre plus
gros drame ça a été beaucoup le drame de
beaucoup de beaucoup de patients parce
qu'effectivement il y a une perte de
chance qui est inouïe avec une perte
aussi de diagnostic de pathologie
importante pour nous c'est ta crève-cœur
et pour nous c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui nous a profondément choqué
parce que notre métier notre code de
déontologie notre notre éthique notre
empathie notre altruisme fait pour
soigner les autres pour soigner nos
patients et ça ça s'était vraiment
quelque chose de de très dommageable et
qui me qui maltère encore quand j'en
parle merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
docteur Perotti
faut revenir à la problématique de
la pénurie de médicaments c'est sûr
qu'elle est plus rifactorielle c'est une
évidence il y a la matière première la
fabrication du médicament on demande il
faut savoir parce que j'en ai parlé avec
plusieurs pharmaciens autour de
chez moi c'est que c'est pas forcément
le médicament qui est en pénurie mais
parfois c'est le blister c'est
l'aluminium c'est tout ce qui va autour
qui peut être en pénurie et si vous
n'avez pas la boîte effectivement vous
commercialisez
les médicaments qui sont fabriqués très
loin de chez nous où il peut y avoir le
transport qui peut se problème on sait
très bien que les
containers qui viennent de Chine et ils
ont triplé de valeur
après le covid donc ça a un coût pour
tout et en particulier pour les
médicaments il y a la distribution donc
on
avec le prix du médicament en France il
est grossiste et puis il y a la de
l'autre côté la consommation et la
pertinence de la prescription
on l'a dit aussi il y a toutes les
médicaments qui sont qui sont pas
consommés il y avait médicament qui sont
prescrits et qui devraient pas l'être
alors ça c'est une évidence je suis
neurologue et je peux vous dire qu'à
longueur de journée je vois des
prescriptions de benzodiazépines qui
sont des toxiques qui alimentent
d'ailleurs les services de chirurgien
orthopédiques parce que si à partir de
80 ans vous prenez une base des épines
le soir et ben vous vous levez la nuit
pour aller aux toilettes les muscles
sont ramollis vous êtes endormis vous
tombez vous avez une fracture du col du
fémur à tous les coups mais le problème
c'est que arrêter une base de des épines
c'est compliqué ça prend du temps il
faut du temps médical si on est bien
d'accord
et c'est une
c'est une problématique
il faut aussi soulever je veux dire je
ferai une petite parenthèse presque
provocatrice c'est que donc je suis
neurologue et je travaille depuis 9 mois
avec une infirmière en pratique avancée
qui exerce en libéral avec moi et il est
indiscutable que la pertinence de la
prise en charge médicale s'améliore
quand on collabore avec une infirmière
impératique avancée qui a le temps
d'écouter le patient bien plus que nous
qui ça peut s'apesantit sur des
problèmes qui nous paraissent annexes
nous et qui ne sont pas je prends un
exemple pour la maladie de Parkinson la
constipation du parking Sonia que EDF
moi malheureusement je saute à pied jour
là dessus et ben je peux vous dire
qu'avec l'infirmière pratique avancée
ils ont le temps d'en parler de trouver
des moyens adaptés et donc je suis un
ardent défenseur de cette prise en
charge collaborative pas d'accéder de
collabor qui nous aident à mieux prendre
en charge le patient et en même temps
cette infirmière en particulier peut
faire prendre parce qu'elle fait des
questions thérapeutiques comme ce
jourdain faisait de la prose sans s'en
rendre compte enfin elles ont rencontré
elle mais le patients
et c'est très pertinent pour le
l'utilisation des médicaments à quelle
heure je les prends comment je les
prends et pas de déperdition et je suis
en meilleure forme et j'ai pas de
complications donc la pertinence de la
prescription c'est savoir arrêter les
médicaments ne savoir ne pas sur
utiliser certains médicaments et
effectivement chez les gens âgés on
parle on parlait tout à l'heure des
pathologies chroniques des gens qui
vivent beaucoup plus vieux c'est une
évidence je fais souvent référence à vos
travaux de 2019 qui montrait que il y
avait une augmentation de 4%
du coût de la santé à cause du
vieillissement de la population
et des maladies chroniques qui diraient
plus longtemps donc ça aussi c'est une
finance si vous avez un
diabétique en hypertendu qui va vivre 10
ans de plus vous allez avoir des
médicaments pendant plus longtemps mais
il faudrait aussi se poser la question
est-ce que je peux baisser certains
médicaments passer 80-85 ans 90 ans
parce que à cet âge-là la pertinence du
médicament est plus la même et je crois
que notre comme l'a dit mon collègue
il faut qu'on puisse avoir des
consultations d'expertise médicale plus
longue s'appuyer sur d'autres
professionnels de santé pour que cette
pertinence soit de soit meilleure parce
que là on est dans malheureusement dans
un système dégradé et il se dégrade à
tous les niveaux
merci
monsieur carvalero je voulais dire
quelque chose compléter
Coulon et après
je voudrais juste réagir par rapport aux
IPA et clarifier la position de médecin
pour demain parce qu'on a été très mis
sur la trémie sur la scène
non je pense pas en fait on découvre les
IPA dans le cadre du suivi c'est ce qui
a expliqué mon collègue et notamment
dans la thérapeutique elle subit de la
thérapeutique des personnes âgées ils
ont toute leur utilité en aval du
médecin et on prône ça et on prône pas
le primo accès des IPA
très bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
pour ces éléments du quotidien et de
l'impact des pénuries sur votre activité
professionnelle
je vous remercie au revoir merci au
revoir